[Musica]
allora il libro delle vacanze
quest'estate per compiti farò poco poco
ogni giorno così li finisco anche in
anticipo e poi posso godermi l'estate
brembate diari affari missino in una
notte a finirli tutti si rischia
[Musica]
ok sole 823 case a dormire adesso così
domani mi sveglio alle cinque mila i
capelli mi trucco calcio colazione
coccarda finisco compiti ecco cosa
mettervi da vestire e arrivo anche in
anticipo perfetto
[Musica]
avete a per faccio l'ultima partita e
poi finisco di fare i compiti
a dormire tutto il resto ancora otto e
mezzo
[Musica]
buongiorno pro am identifico no
oh cavolo grandissimo va beh intanto
elena del professore arrivano sempre in
ritardo e qualche giorno quindi
sicuramente così star messi
[Musica]
rita del primo giorno di scuola di
buongiorno bambini ogni tanto mi
confondo con la mia scuola delle
elementari
volevo dirvi siccome oggi il primo
giorno di scuola e potente disegnare
disegnate pure mediare nel quaderno
grazie
[Musica]
è il primo giocato disegneremo basso
apritevi pro pagina 93 che si siano
professori movie quest'anno soprattutto
lei
[Musica]
[Applauso]
buongiorno ragazzi sulla vostra nuova
vinse niente perché abbiate passato
telephone e patate
non vi preoccupate faremo tutto con
calma non solo una di quelle a cui piace
a segnare tanti compiti
[Musica]
credo che abbiamo cambiato tutti i
professori tutti nuovi giovani simpatici
bravi soprattutto speriamo che non ci
sia lei
[Musica]
[Applauso]
anita hai studiato e capito che abbiamo
assegnato per far sì che ha studiato
tutto il capitolo intero e più studiato
il capitolo dopo così tra caracas e sono
sicuro che quest'anno inizierà propri
impegni
grazie però di nuovo compagno per
piacere azio
[Musica]
speriamo che questo non sia qualche
nuovo compagno di cross e qualche
ragazzina
[Musica]
bella chiederanno finirli non richiedono
così così definisco tutti oggi siamo
perfetti
non vi preoccupate sono sicura di libro
delle vacanze lo avete completato tutto
certo che le abbiamo forti tutti abbiamo
finito tutto il libro quindi ora
iniziamo piano piano con il programma
non c'è bisogno di perdere tempo vedere
con libro delle vacanze che però vabbè
time chiederanno mai come cheese e le
famose il primo giorno
[Musica]
schiarite quelle facce oggi andremo
semplicemente leggere un testo
leggeremo un testo del nuovo libro di
letteratura potete andare a pagina 111 i
compiti delle vacanze
[Musica]
a1 diario nuovo bellissimo di ottenere
pulito bello ordinato e tantissimi
disegni
[Musica]
ecco fatto completato 10 fragilissimi
perché mi è piaciuto il video aspettate
perché ora ci sono i retroscena in
inglese mano blu per le sere tagliate in
cui ne combinano di tutti i colori
parlano perché come troppo ridere
in più vi volevo dire questa è l'agenda
me come avrete visto del pd si può
personalizzare e fantastica c'è io
quando doposcuola avrebbe sognato una
scelta del genere ed è cover adesive che
potete attaccare e staccare se nel retro
che davanti così non vi annoiate sempre
con la storica cover ma potete cambiarlo
durante l'anno in più a festini stickers
che potete attaccare nel vago e nelle
varie pagine se volete farvi un biplano
e pianificare sono per i compiti non
sono compiti ma le giornate di studio le
giornate fuori con gli amici io ad onore
di stickers io ho sempre avuto
l'emozione per gli stickers tu potevi
sapere se anche per voi è così e poi
dentro o comunque bellissimo perché ha
un tempo di disegni da colorare come
avrete già visto nel video e sono
composti che mandava quindi rilassanti
sono varie pagine più delle frasi
bellissime in questa pagina su scritto
coloro che sognano di giorno stanno
molte cose che sfuggono a chi sogna
soltanto di notte ed è una situazione di
edgar allan poe in più qua a fianco c'è
lo spazio esercito può essere la chiave
usa questo spazio per trasformare i tuoi
sogni i nuovi progetti quindi
praticamente è una vision board
io vi avevo parlato in un altro video
delle pizze un board qua potete
disegnare con quello che sognate che si
realizzi la tennista per quale scena
abbia divertito di più del video noi
siamo divertiti tantissimo a girarlo
lasciatemi questa intanto nei commenti
di palese la mia è piaciuta di più e ora
siete pronti a vedere i retroscena i blu
per stupro che succede che voi non
vedete
eccoli qua e mi raccomando lasciate un
bel live che volete avere né altri video
come sulla scuola
chiamare il numero
[Musica]
buongiorno ragazzi avete fatto i compiti
mi vedo tra i compiti di limone siccome
mi avete fatti tutti dal primo
all'ultimo
iniziamo dalla fine libro quindi aprire
l'ultima pagine dei compiti che abbiamo
segnato
[Musica]
a fare ambiente per questo pgt è partita
bene
[Musica]